hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible classical game that was
played in round one of this year's
Norway chess it is alireza fuja versus
uhireza still the world number two in
classical rating only uh topped by the
former world champion Magnus Carlsen and
Lucas making his way comfortable uh in
the in the top 20 heading for that top
15 and then of course maybe even top 10.
so uh let's see what happened in this
one gookish had a pretty bad event uh
before the Norwich has the the blitz
section he defeated Magnus cross and
then he lost pretty much all of the
games but now this is classical a
completely different Beast to tackle and
it's going to be very interesting to see
how how players get accustomed to the
different time format so alireza has the
white pieces and he opens with Pawn to
E4 and also here's a nice photo of uh
gookish and his birthday cake as we've
mentioned in the uh two of my previous
videos it was his 17th birthday during
the blitz section and the organizers I
made this nice cake for him so there you
have it now let's enjoy the game so E4
we have E5 by gokash Knight to F3
Knights the C6 and the bishop to C4 the
Italian game is on the board with Bishop
to C5 The Joker piano and now again the
moment of truth about alireza goes for
Ponte D3 The Joker pianissimo variation
Knight to F6 with castles and pawn to D6
now we have C3 H6 and Knight B to D2 so
this has all been played uh many many
times nothing new here Ponte A5
preparing Ponte foreign
and now castles we have Knight to F1 and
now uh upon the A4
uh usually uh Bishop D6 is the more
common move here but Google goes for
Ponte A4 we have Bishop to B5 now
fighting for the for the center uh and
pawn to A3 advancing the pawn all the
way so of course this will be met with
Pawn to B4 Bishop to B6 and now uh there
uh there are a few games that reach this
uh exact same position for example uh
Hans Neiman defeated hike martiros and
last year with knights to G3 but here we
have Bishop back to C4 uh and now Knight
the E7 uh Shifting the Knight over to G6
and there is one game in the database
that reached this position where Bishop
to E3 was played uh lucasfan 4 has
played it against David Anthony Haro in
the 2018 European Blitz Championship but
that game ended by by
um uh Lucas losing but here we have
Knight the G3 and it is now as of move
13 that we have a completely new game so
Knights the G6 continues re-maneuvering
his pieces Ponte H3 and now Pawn to C6
preparing Pawn to D5 with Bishop to B3
preparing to shift the bishop over to
this diagonal and now Pawn to D5 uh
Google says all right you haven't really
shown anything I'm gonna play D5 as you
haven't prevented it and let's just um
uh trade some Pawns in the center and
the reason you can do this because look
at this after he captures on D5 your E5
Pawn is also hanging the reason you can
do this is because after Knight captures
on D5 you are also attacking the C3 Pawn
uh and it doesn't really matter if you
play Bishop captures on D5 because uh
then C captures on D5 and you still
can't capture on E5 if Knight captures
on E5 you run into the oldest trick in
the book Knight characters on E5 Rook
captures and E5 and now Bishop captures
an F2 which check will pick up the Rook
on E5 so that's always an issue in these
lines of the Joker pianissimo so instead
Bishop to D2 and now we have Bishop to
E6 uh sorry not Queen to D2 Bishop to D2
and now Bishop to E6 and now Knight the
H5 the problem with the e-pawn now is
the exact same one you will end if you
don't believe me with bush captures an
FD check and again Queen F6 check will
pick up the Rook on E5 so you can pretty
much never catch capture this sunlight
to H5 instead Bishop to C7 now the pawn
is nicely defended and pawn to D for
alirez and now ready to execute this and
uh it's not easy to meet the meet this
move you should play Knife the B6 or
Knight to F6 but not the move that
gookish played Lucas played e captures
on D4 and now alireza has a chance to
achieve a great position but it's not
easy to spot why feel free to pause the
video for the first time and find the
absolute best move for alireza while I
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredible idea as both of the Players
missed it and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Bishop
captures on H6 that's the good stuff and
now after Bishop captures on H6 uh it's
not easy to meet this move uh you can't
capture back if you capture back then
Queen captures on D4 and black pretty
much resides Checkmate is coming you
can't play F6 because then the bishop
hangs uh the only uh a viable uh you
know series of moves is Bishop to E5 but
then you just capture it because you
just don't care you're gonna give up
material and open up the black king
black will try to offer a queen trade
you will play even Rook captures on E6
now threatening Rook captures and G6 if
black wants to trade Queens first so now
Knight captures on E6 and now Queen G4
threatening Bishop captures and queen
captures and G6 so we're gonna play
something like Knight to G5 but now
Knights the D4 and there are no moves
here for black you're just gonna get
destroyed there's really nothing you can
and play here more like H4 are coming
the Knight moves Queen captures and G6
because the F Pawn is pinned you can
also bring the Knight to F5 uh so many
possibilities here but none of them end
the well for black so what you will be
able to do after Bishop captures on H6
is playing Knight Dita F4 right away but
then you've just lost the pawn and it's
uh it's uh losing by force uh I mean the
pawn maybe the position can still be
held but it's very hard to say like
Bishop captures on B3 Queen captures
captures an F4 Knight captures an F4
Bishop captures on F4 and now the uh
variation ends with Rook to E4 and this
is how you keep your extra Pawn the
bishop now has to move you move it
somewhere or you defend it it doesn't
really matter it's a bishop D6 real
capture is if Queen to F6 you can even
double up on the D5 black will defend
and okay the the game goes on but it's
white goes up a pawn and has excellent
uh chances in this game however after he
captures on D4 alireza play the Knight
captures on D4 he just um a recaptures
material and now Queen to D6 gookish now
threatens uh Queen to HD check so
Knights the G3 and now Rook a to d8
doubling up on the D file we have Knight
captures and E6 creating a weakness an
E6 F captures an E6 and now Queen to G4
honing in on that isolated E6 Pawn uh
Knight the E5 chases the queen back with
Queen to E2 and now just Knight captures
on B4 as the bishop and D2 is undefended
all it is a doesn't just uh give it up
for nothing he plays Bishop to G5 he
says I will ruin your Pawn structure
before capturing back and okay as The
Rook is hanging this is definitely the
best course of action so H captures on
G5 C captures on B4 and now Pawn to G6
cutting off the knight from advancing
and also the White Queen Rook 8 to D1
attacking the queen and queen captures
on B4 and there are many moves you could
consider here like Rook captures and d8
also Knights the E4 is very strong going
after the GP five Pawn but alireza plays
Bishop captures on E6 with check and
even though it's a very forcing move it
comes with check it seems like it's
something that you should definitely
play It's kind of the move that uh also
loses the game for him and it's not um
and not simple a king DJ was played Rook
the B1 attacks the bookish queen and now
Queen to F4 just putting pressure on
that F2 Pawn as the queen and Rook are
attacking it and also Rook the D2 is
coming so how do you stop this uh well
Rook captures on B7 that's one way to do
it now it's a very tricky idea because
now uh Rook to D2 can be met with the
simple Queen to E3 you you keep the
tension the F2 Pawn is defended and also
the bishop and C7 is hanging so because
of the bishop and C7 is hanging black
will not have time to start capturing an
F2 so instead we have Knights the D3
here uh ended the problem for alireza is
that even though okay his position is uh
probably still manageable uh the problem
is that he has only 20 seconds on the
clock or maybe 23 seconds to be exact
and uh gookish has over 25 minutes and
here you have two hours of time control
before reaching move 40 but the uh
without increment you have to reach move
40 uh to gain access to increment so
here all it is it basically has to make
uh 10 more moves within those 23 seconds
and you might think well okay alireza is
probably the the best bullet player in
the world surely he can make 10 moves in
20 seconds yes online but not the when
your hand physically has to move you
know through uh through space uh so
that's a kind of an issue and also you
have to be very very precise those those
would have to be 10 uh incredibly
precise moves just to survive this
position and here after this Knight the
the D3 remove okay the F2 Pawn is saying
you have to be
uh you have to be again very precise you
have to play Rook Dev one to defend but
alireza tried to get uh uh tricky he
played Rook to D1 and now the position
is again completely winning for good
cash so feel free to pause the video and
try to spot this uh spectacular move uh
while I give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh realizing that
sometimes the night also goes forward
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is night the C1
alireza obviously missed this and now
there's just no coming back from this
and even if there was there's just no
it's physically impossible for him to
make all of the moves within the set
time even though okay you can actually
make the moves but not uh not the
precise ones okay now the it's pretty
much forced because your queen is
hanging you have to play Rook captures
on C1 uh so uh Rook captures on C1 was
played and now Queen captures and C1
with check we have King to H2 and now uh
of course uh with Knight to F1 it's
still a bit more playable but I mean few
seconds on the clock Rook to D2 was
played attacking the queen now the F2
Pawn is also super vulnerable the bishop
here is doing a fine job so Queen to E4
and not just the Rook F captures an F2
even giving up the bishop on C7 and
there's nothing to consider here Rook
captures on C7 a rook cap Sanji to check
Queen captures Rook captures King
captures and you might think well okay
alireza does have three pieces or rather
two pieces on The Rook for a queen but
Queen to D2 check and he was in this
position unmoved 37 that alireza future
lost on time but also to be fair in a
completely lost position uh the problem
is uh his King has to move if you play
King to H1 or King to G1 just Queen to
E1 check nicely connect with the Knight
end with the bishop here if you go uh to
F1 to sort of cover D1 squared and queen
to F or Chuck picks up the Rook on C7 so
whatever you play here you will lose
material either a a bishop or a knight
or a rook and then the queen will easily
overpower the uh well whatever white has
left uh so yeah a pretty incredible game
by by both of them alireza did have that
one opportunity when uh agukish
carelessly captured on D4 and allowed
this bishop captures an H6 move but it's
uh it's very hard to understand why
alireza would miss this I mean it is
definitely within his
ability to calculate this he is one of
the sharpest tactical players
currently playing chess but it's just
one of those moves that you don't see
because I mean yeah Bishop captures
Queen captures and D4 threatens
Checkmate and now once you see it of
course you know that okay I mean let's
just play this you know with absolute
best defense from black uh black will be
down upon but still white will have
winning chances
um uh but yeah very very strange foreign
after that so yeah once again we have
this opportunity where after uh this
position of the Joker piano uh White did
not go for the Evans Gambit he went for
the strongest jokopianismo variation and
lost the game with the white piece so I
mean what do you what do you really have
to show for it yeah I mean play the
Evans Gambit live a little you know uh
at least that's that's my opinion uh and
also here if you guys are interested uh
here are the uh the results of round one
so while it is a lost to Lucas as you
can see three points are awarded for a
full win in the classical so it's much
much better to Win In classical than to
get a drawing classical and then win in
the Armageddon uh
Drew their games uh but then Mommy dear
have won the Armageddon game Notre back
and Anish also Drew their classical game
then Anish won the Armageddon game Fabi
defeated Magnus in the classical game uh
we already uh seen that if you haven't
do check it out it's my previous video
and Wesley so and Hikaru Drew their
classical game and then Wesley defeated
Hikaru Nakamura in their Armageddon game
so there you have it and also for those
of you who are interested in the live
ratings uh there's a you know a lot
going on here you can see for example
Fabiano uh jumped three three places
he's currently on number 15 uh plus 15
rating points he's currently number four
in the world okay Magnus alireza and the
ding still the the top three but as you
can see Fabiano very very close to
overtaking a dingler and spot as world
number three then you have some movement
Anish giri also he dropped even though
he gained rating he dropped the number
seven uh Wesley chilling in eight uh
vishwanathan Anand always in the top 10
regardless of what's happening in the
world Robert also jumped up four squares
uh he's an uh number 10 currently also
big winners are gukesh who is currently
on plus 10 points uh he jumped to number
15 so he he went up for for places you
and he also have six places uh so yeah a
lot Happening Here Abdul satrov in
number 20 and so on and so on but this
is only round one we'll see what happens
until the rest of the tournament we
might see a big big shift in power in
the world's top 20. uh so yeah that's
the game uh and a little bit of extra
info hope you enjoyed that I would like
to thank Marcus grebel abundak Pang
represents YouTube Michael Zacharias and
David gasparian for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as you usual you can check
to my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
incredible tournament until it finishes
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day